I have the will to eat,
but I'm feeling weaker than I expected,
so I'm not sure if I can go back home. Excuse me, but I have the
same
skin
tone as before, and I think you're the one wearing makeup. You
look beautiful to Rifa-sama.  What I want is the
second daughter's duty, so it's all for Rifa-sama's sake,
right? What are you doing? You're
just making a fool of yourself.
Ah, stop
hurting, it's hurting. Sooner or later, the
poison will spread throughout your body.
Good thing this is you.  You can become beautiful, too.The corpse is just
like Rifa-sama, with pale skin,
droopy eyes, and a body that looks like it can't eat.Do you know why
this was banned?
Because it's a poison that Rifa-sama thought would please her.  I'm sure you're
right, but you think you're the one who doesn't think about anything and
is happy about the poison you've written.
Hurry, wash your mouth and wash your face. If you continue
like this, you'll touch a sick person on this floor.
Hurry up and clean it up.
[Applause]
Yes,
women are really scary. Let
's go.